all right for this logo critique we're
gonna actually getting a lot deeper than
I normally do because there's lots of
things to work on and we're given the
doctor files so that also makes it a lot
easier for me to critique it and here's
one of those things about letter forms
they share common elements and makes
them a family imagine if you came from a
family of really tall skinny people and
then there was like a short runt it
would feel out of place and logos and
letter form design is very much like
this so once you establish a certain
rhythm angles balance and weight you
need to make sure that those are
consistently applied across the board
these are telltale signs of somebody who
understands the basic concept but it
hasn't mastered yet so buckle in we're
gonna go deep on this one all right
devote what's the problem with this I
think the ease and the oh and the tea
all the curves are too far down maybe
you are correct the overshoot is too
much and there's another problem too is
a look at the thick and thins right yeah
a modern typeface like this has great
contrast between the thick and fins so
the thick and the thin and this feels
like from a different era where the
thickened things weren't has more of an
old style or transitional style so what
we want to do I'm gonna take this I'm
gonna scale it up okay so then I think
optically feels more in the same family
as the V which is which I think is the
most unique character of them all
I like this V quite a lot okay now I'm
gonna take this whole thing and I must
scale it down a hair that might be too
little but let's see what happens we're
doing everything optically you guys so
if you look at it it feels like it's on
the same line that's what matters does
it feel like it's on the line or does it
need to be a little bit bigger I think
it needs to be a little bit bigger okay
just a little bit i'ma hit scale and hit
return I'm gonna hit 101 degrees or a
percentage how's that better okay
so that's my new overshoot line so I'm
gonna grab
a ruler and guide that point right there
okay and I'm gonna do the same with the
top theoretically it should be exactly
the same top and bottom assume that it
is it's not but little is live with that
now I have some issues here I think when
you have one flourish one kind of custom
letter I don't think you want to do it
to every single letter so for me these
little things start to make it feel like
it's Elvis or jolly Christmasy kind of
thing yeah so if there's a little funny
to me so I'm gonna delete these things
is that okay yes all right so I'm not
sure that the tea feels funny but so I'm
gonna leave the tea for right now and
let's hide the guides let's look at this
let's step back for a little bit we only
fixed the oh and that's it how does it
feel right now it feels better but the
ease and the tea need to be adjusted to
match the overshoot though that's
correct so we're gonna keep going now I
want to make sure that we're moving in
the right direction before I start
changing all these letters right so if
you feel like yeah we've made some
positive changes which it sounds like
you are saying if I interpret that I
wanna check the measurement of this
theoretically this vertical stroke which
would be the same as this seems a little
shy yeah if that seems shy like I wonder
why
[Music]
why is that there
[Music]
I'm not sure so I'm no expert at this
kind of typeface so let's just type in a
bower Bodoni okay so I'm going to do a
couple of things here you guys first I
converted this thing to an outline I
want to see what a master letter form
looks like I'm going to study this so
I'm gonna take this Oh check this out
8:2 is oh it's exactly the same time so
that's a problem okay so we probably
need to fix that the next whoops the
next thing I want to do is I want to
check this against this as it should be
okay the curve of the bowl of the e this
part here the shoulder whatever gonna
call this is actually thicker than the
vertical stroke as it should be I'm
gonna compare that to this this two is
wider the diagonal stroke is thicker or
wider than the vertical stroke we know
some things there let's look at the bowl
let me ungroup this take this letter
I'll move it over here compare so
Erika's on the money on this - they're
very similar some things have been
changed right so it tapers down faster
on the right hand side you guys see what
I'm saying yes okay so if you guys
haven't taken a lettering course or you
slept through lenses lettering klore
course I can't even say it then you
could do this and you can kind of study
from how the Masters do it but make sure
you study from a really well drawn
typeface from a reputable type boundary
that's really important now let's fix
the D yeah let's do that I'm gonna okay
I'm gonna take this here and I'm gonna
see if I can do this in one fell swoop
almost like that I've done shift and
grab back zoom in a little bit here take
this and move it over and we've solved
that problem okay I'm gonna look at this
relative to this a little bit wider so
we're safe hold on yeah a little wider
we're safe okay
okay and let's check it out yes or not
so this is not as wide as it needs to be
so I'm gonna select these points so it
looks like it's out and then it flat
flattens out right here
this o is drawn very differently than
the way that our oh is drawn so we're
gonna have some problems here where we
were looking at this here ladies and it
pretty much lines up right and we can
use that but ours is not going to be
able to do that because where this
flattens out
it looks funky hmm oh babe let me bring
it out right there so first of all I can
get rid of this thing right here
I'll bring it in it's not a problem for
us so we need to look at the way this
transitions into this they'll make sure
it's not too thick or bring us in a
little bit more it doesn't look right
it looks terrible yeah yeah so what we
should do is we should fix this one to
make it work in this thickness and then
we'll go from there
I think that's kind of what they had
before so I'm gonna delete this note
let's go one thing at a time okay do we
want to get rid of the ball on the tee
the terminal that's what it's called the
terminal on the team it won't get rid
that terminal I kinda like that there's
I think one I think ones enough and
Erica you're saying it's cool so for
those people that don't like it it's
gone and then we're gonna fix the frost
bar but where should we make it
crossover maybe with that
I need to fix this part of the Oh so I'm
gonna go rulers and drag this thing down
and hit that point right there don't so
I need to fix this thing up I think
that's the same line it is okay that
means we have a problem down here too
this is too thick maybe alright guys
Internet's number one which is original
number two has some modifications we
drop the ball terminal of the T but I
didn't fix the e at that point so that
looks a little funky but look at number
three
number [ __ ] new Morell [ __ ] [ __ ] which
one do you guys like the most let me
know let us know type it in check this
out if you have a typeface like bower
Bodoni or Dido and you have this mono
Stroke thing here like this and then it
tapers out to something yes I'm gonna
show you how to draw that so that this
arc doesn't start to get tapered in and
out so when you draw it by my hand
manually you can look like that
sometimes mm-hmm look a little wonky
yes this happened
[Music]
okay so what I want to do is I'm gonna
increase the stroke to something light
like that okay let's pretend like that's
going to be our e it's not a grade II
admit that what I'm gonna do is gonna
select this part guys I'm an option
drive over here
like this I'm gonna take this I'm gonna
scale this part down to do the
transition right I'm almost done I'm
almost done if you were blinking if you
went to the bathroom you missed it so
I'm going to use the scissor tool i'ma
hit cut I'll cut it right here okay I'm
gonna hide this part I'm gonna join this
part which is command J I see what you
do then I'm going to then fill this with
black trixie hopping why didn't they
look black X [ __ ] and you this truck
okay
then I'm here command option 3 and show
that thing and I am done oh yeah do you
might be sitting there thinking well
Chris how I'm gonna get the other side
will hit oh and reflect that thing copy
right and then what we can do is we can
delete these points leap select these
two points hit command J in three two
one the East kind of now I didn't draw
this carefully obviously so this
wouldn't need to go out to here mm-hmm
but I can do that since it's drawn in a
certain way that it's super easy to do
now this is jank it's too low we want to
cut it up a little higher so I'm going
to take a box here and probably chop it
right around there say so it's like that
and go into divide I think it's this one
Oh mine is front there you go and select
this so it remembers the stroke width
and hit pen and just draw and yeah no
bring it right to here we're probably
have some problems the way that connects
but I cut it too high cut it too high
hmm obviously I'm not an expert matter
form designer there you go
okay let me know if you guys agree or
disagree with the changes that I've made
in the comments below it hit like if you
liked this video don't forget to
subscribe and hit the bell icon if you
want to be notified if you want a deeper
dive into a local design course make
sure you check out the course that we
have called logo design and construction
that's on the Academy site and we'll
provide a link somewhere here and last
but not least if you want to have your
work critiqued and review make sure you
follow us on Facebook it's the mature
work when we call for submissions that's
it that's all I have for you guys see
you next time namaste